which card should you use when shopping  a reminder that using a credit card has  a price but that processing fee could be  a thing of the past as any pays voted to  cap bank charges for domestic and  cross-border transactions the cups are  fixed on Ibaka Simone of 0.3 in the case  of credit card and 0.2 in the case of  David Carr merchants charge over 10  billion euros a year for transaction  fees now retailers will make a 6 billion  euro saving and those benefits will  trickle down to the consumer now which  we do is transferring those costs away  from the banks to the retailers and they  will print a benefit the first but of  course later on the consumers will  benefit because retailers have more  competition and they will lower the  prices as well and it could also be the  start of breaking up the monopolies of  big companies like Visa and MasterCard  as retailers will no longer have to  blankly accept cards that have high  charges set by the card issuer